get your home summer ready for the heat
with the help of envy energy the
sponsors of this next segment
well did you know that nv energy
actually comes to your home for free and
does a power shift bundle assessment and
it's a great way to learn how to save
money and energy as we head into the
summer so we're going to get an up close
and personal look let's go ahead inside
and check it out one of the things that
is really important as we get into
spring and the season where it starts to
get warmer here in southern nevada is we
offer a service called our power bundle
we will provide a technician who you can
see he's doing right now install a free
smart thermostat provide a home energy
assessment that will tell you the
efficiencies of your home and what
inefficiencies your home may have and
provide you with products and services
such as maybe led light bulbs or filters
for your ac unit things like that which
can help you on your journey to energy
efficiency well right now as we get into
spring
when the season gets hot this can start
to be the time when you can start to
save on your bill getting a thermostat
like the smart thermostat that's being
installed can save approximately about
120 a year because it is programmable
because you can set it to different
schedules that you have when you're
either at home or not you can control it
from your phone you control it from the
computer then they will also look at the
rest of the home and do other things
that you can find that you can be more
efficient on it could take anywhere from
about 45 minutes to an hour and a half
depending but the best thing about it
100 free we are we will take care of the
cost to do everything to make sure that
this customer any customer can save
money at their home all year long okay
so adam the thermostat has officially
been installed and now we're moving
through them to the next step of the
process what's happening behind us here
so what's happening here is they're
doing the final checks at the vent so
when the tech gets to your home they
will do a pre-check to make sure that
the event is is working efficiently it's
if the temperature is coming out as what
the thermostat says it is then they'll
do the thermothat installation and when
they're done they'll come back to the
vent to make sure it's working as
efficiently or even more efficiently
than it was before one of the things the
assessment will take a look at is the
appliances in the home with your ac
they'll look at your fridge to look at
your appliances such as your uh
dishwasher things like that and they'll
look to see if they are
inefficient and there can be some
upgrades done
we have a new program that we're
launching this year that will then
assist with incentives for appliance for
a more efficient appliance we have a
great program for our low and limited
income customers we will provide a free
refrigerator and or
electric clothes dryer free of charge to
those who can qualify but we do have
this new program that will look at all
these and the assessment can kind of
give you an idea if that's something you
should be interested in one of the great
things we have is our equal payment
program takes an average of your bill
over the whole year and you have the
same payment for those 12 months which
means you're not going to have the high
bill spike in the summer you're going to
have the same amount it's going to be
repetitive you're going to know what it
is you have a lot of different options
things like that things like choose your
choose your pay date and different
options for customers to help them know
when they can manage their savings and
manage their bills we want our customers
to think of us as our partner with them
in the energy world so
having these thermostats doing the
assessment starting the journey with a
led bulb or
the filters just begins that journey to
understand that energy if you save
energy now you can save it during the
hottest times of the year which will
save you the most money
book your free powership bundled
appointment at nbenergy.com we'll be
you